viele hatten in stellung
eigentlich stehen sie mit beiden beinen
im zivilen leben als
kraftfahrzeugmeister in sozialarbeiter
in eltern durchschnittsalter 38 und
jetzt ausbildung zum reservisten
wenn man ist extrem gestresst wenn man
eine waffe in der hand hat das nicht
irgendwie ein spielzeug man wächst über
seine grenzen hinaus das finde ich super
mann entdeckt noch mehr positives was in
einem steckt kameradschaft des unfassbar
super schnell und sehr eng ich sage
immer zu unseren tempel beginnen wir
sind hier nicht im dschungelcamp weder
spaß noch spielerei die ausbildung ist
eine ernst zu nehmende angelegenheit es
gibt sie seit vier jahren zwei mal zehn
tage lang
die runde an die richtung beziehen
stellung sie sabrina romancier nun haben
wir schon dem training erfahren als ihr
sohn zur bundeswehr gehen und sich
spontan angemeldet jetzt hat das ehepaar
tann farbe im gesicht muss das lager für
die nacht aufbauen orientierungs
bändchen anbringen
ein klopfen
die stange passiert so aber jetzt wo
sollte er in rheine
möglichst geräuschlos geprobt wird
schließlich der ernstfall
damit muss man rechnen um das zu lernen
dazu gehört auch fast so auszusehen wie
der wald
müssen uns anpassen man spürt es nicht
also mal macht es drauf natürlich ist
dann erst mal lustig weil man ja nicht
jeden tag so grün die bundeswehr sucht
reservisten für den heimatschutz also
für landesverteidigung und
katastrophenfall es gibt ja keine
wehrpflicht mehr diese gruppe wird auf
dem truppenübungsgelände in baumholder
gedrillt 19 frauen und männer was hat
sie dazu bewogen
wir wollten einfach mal in das
berufsleben eines soldaten rein schauen
was sie so leisten das war einfach kommt
also der erste grund und natürlich auch
was für deutschland zu tun dann kann das
rufen sind dass wir einspringen können
damit wir wissen was wir zu tun haben
wenn es zur verteidigung des landes ist
man möchte ja eigentlich sicher leben
weiterleben
gute stellungen finden sie ausheben
tarnen und dann wache halten das hat
oberste priorität denn ein lager
errichtet wird da liegen sie fast reglos
wenn es nötig ist stundenlang
nächste übung auf das tv programm
bezieht jahre ihre stellung sowie
angesagt taktisch annähern mit rein
gleiten zum schluss klar soweit gut dann
produkt das gewehr im anschlag laufen
sie los unterholz und gleiten rhein in
ihre stellungen die einen mit fließenden
bewegungen andere brauchen ein bisschen
länger
wir wollten einen neuen weg öffnen dass
menschen die bisher noch keinen dienst
in der bundeswehr geleistet haben einen
zugang in die reserve finden und das
neben ihrem berufs- und familienleben
sie werden behandelt wie jeder andere
kuh der sich für den anderen den aktiven
dienst in der bundeswehr bewirbt auch
heißt also partner erdboden stadt
weiches bett immerhin gibt es tipps fürs
feuer machen
ein feuerzeug mit
panzer tape also gewebe band und einen
labello hat den vorteil dieser labello
ist wasserdicht verpackt mit dem täglich
oben kann man ein stück weiter
einsetzen und wenn man das mit dem
labello drängt fängt das sofort an zu
brennen also als anzünder ist es ideal
und man hat immer geschmeidige leben im
feld
anderer tag andere herausforderung
schießtraining
geschossen wird mit dem sturmgewehr 36
und mit scharfer munition
die angehenden reservisten haben schon
einiges gelernt dass hier ist das
schießtraining teil 2 es ist ein top
trefferbild wird blieben auch sie
richtig gut aus hier ist auf den 1 wobei
das alles in der scheibe drin ist ja das
ziel ist bekämpft also muss der auftrag
ausgeführt tipptopp dranbleiben er
südosten zufrieden sie können auch leben
dass sabrina reservistin werden will ist
in ihrem privaten umfeld nicht bei allen
gut angekommen
natürlich gab es eine gruppe gemeinde
warum machst du es noch mal und dann gab
es ein kohl hat gesagt mega gut ab also
es ist wirklich komplett gemischt wie
eine waffe zu bedienen ist als inga
bereits von der jagd direkt nach der
schule wollte sie schon zum bund doch
damals hätte das für sie als frau
sanitätsdienst oder core bedeutet jetzt
viele jahre später ist ihr ziel soldaten
der reserve auch wenn es manchmal
schwache momente gibt man denkt halt
immer mal wenn man irgendwo steht
irgendwas macht dann tut an der rücken
weh oder die füße und dann denk mal
warum mache ich das jetzt hier aber am
ende des tages
ist man eigentlich immer froh das muss
gemacht hat vieles was sie hier lernen
sagt sie ja auch für ihren zivilen
alltag wichtig disziplin teamgeist
hilfestellung sich engagieren für sein
land das es das was für alle gezählt
seitdem ukraine konflikt ist ja das
thema bundeswehr sowohl in der
gesellschaft wie auch in der politik
eigentlich schwimmer wegzudenken und
jeder der sich als reservist engagiert
ist natürlich auch in seinem privaten
umfeld in seinem familiären umfeld einen
mittler für die gesellschaft sondern
auch für die bundeswehr überhaupt der
ukraine konflikt ali haben sich
angemeldet bevor der krieg ausgebrochen
ist ein thema ist er trotzdem
sorgen definitiv das macht ja jeden
sommer programm hier ist oder zu hause
setzt sollte es eigentlich jeden
beschäftigen es ist irgendwann den toren
von europa
wo man dann denkt
könnte dann ja doch sein dass sich da
irgendwie
konfrontiert werde reservist sein ist
eben auch eine verantwortung und alle
hoffen dass sie ihr land nie mit der
waffe verteidigen ist